what would recognize this guy's y equals
two sine X plus root 3 in this case what
I'm doing is thinking about each of the
pieces one time just like before but
noticing again they interact with each
other so keeps breaking the sign it is
really funny the first thing that I
think is easier to recognize is 2 sine X
what's the difference between sine X and
cosine mmm yes the employees stretched
out like this okay so if I got literally
n since we're doing a bit of working you
might as well do this to me I didn't
take this original guy right I sent one
then two is directly involved in double
the height and this guy which is
negative 1 will be down get stretch the
opposite direction so I'll call that
magician right once you've got that in
place zeros when you double dealers what
do you get 0 are they're going to stay
put 1 2 3 and now you go fishing right
so I'm just going to connect the dots
that's good enough for it okay so this
is true sine X now I need to do this
plus root 3 what does it mean it means
there's a vertical shift which is why
you can see conveniently on my second
set of axes I've expected this whole
thing which used to be symmetrical
around these ex-athlete or even itself
symmetrical the same amount above and
below I'm moving the whole thing up
right I'm not going to get as much below
as I did before
now our range used to be negative 2 to 2
like we seen it before we add root 3 to
everything the range also moved by that
root 3 no now you're never really going
to get assessed sufficiently on knowing
any of the decimal places of root true
but I think it's helpful to know
it's roughly 1.7 because what that means
is now I've got a rough idea of how far
this is going to go this it used to be -
it's going to be about 3.7 and this
issue's to be negative 2 is going to be
about negative zero point 3 which is why
I've got to chain you a little bit down
here okay so I'm going to draw it in I
only need to see approximation to
decimal to work out scale but I'm
actually going to - 2 - 3 3 I'm going to
write it exactly on there that ok just
beyond mucking with the range right now
let's call that what's the Midway line
going to be ok so like what used to be
here
used to be 0 will notice the rooftop
restraint of that in and if I upper
boundary will be super cute ok now I
find it helpful if I were doing this on
paper what I would do is I would put a
very light pencil line right down the
middle
I can't do that with a white board
marker so I put a solid line it's my
guideline I put it in just so I can
hijack my ability to do these lines
quite well solve it over the middle is
okay so I'm going to call that halfway
and I've got a pass through right
through the middle and then I'm going to
get my high point and my low point okay
does that look good so far ok now that
I've joined the dots let's ecologist
so here is um you know we have some
amount of reason he is my graph of y
equals two sine X plus root 3 beside my
class of y equal to sine X the picture
is done however although now that I've
drawn it I realize I have to supply
additional information namely these
lines okay you got intercepts you better
tell me what they are now how do you
work out intercepts of anything like if
I gave you this how would you work out
the x intercept of that thing I know you
know they are but how do you work
Mountain marketer you let y equal 0
because that is the equation or the
x-axis this is where include 0 so then
that this is my equation to find these
guys and if I believe another like that
over here choose find X intercepts and I
love you like this as well right
I'm going to solve to sign and plus 3
equals 0 so this question is about
graphics but all of a sudden we have
found to graph this exceptionally and
accurately wait a second
unlearning the poor little like stuff I
know about just fall contrition graphs
in science okay
which is why as I've been trying to
convince you if you learn to solve two
equations through graphing that it's not
paid you back because then when you come
to graphing you'd use that knowledge to
do your trig equation so I'm going to
rearrange a little bit and then I want
you to help me out I'm going to subtract
root 3 from both sides and then I'm
going to divide by 2
so now this is what I want to solve okay
now just in whichever way you feel
comfortable maybe if you're like no I
like quadrants they're they're happy for
me which coordinates am I in your inside
it for now here's the wonderful thing
about if you are good enough at graphing
to number one the quadrants
could you not already have told me that
it was the third and fourth quadrants
just by looking at this did you see that
look where am i graphing between what's
the domain I'm graphing to it north to
350 this middle points at 180 is this
not subservient four quadrants from 180
360 so I mean you can use this apply
this tip but you actually already knew
that information okay so now I need to
say what is the exact value you would go
through 3 3 onto its side so we 60
degrees once it okay in the third and
fourth quadrant
what does 60 degrees look like you've
got one a-plus and you've got 360 - like
so so
by the way I really like this one it
just helps me get the answer right when
I get to this point here if I've made a
mistake it's much easier to find my
mistake when I come back an hour later
is be fair if I think is right here now
come back what do you think - 4300 how
good is your Brown book in terms of
scale wasn't I good now if you are
looking at this line tear right and you
say and this is why in verse three
domestic functions are their whole own
topic in extension one agency okay if
you just look at this right and you say
oh cool I know what to do to get rid of
this sign I'll go shift sign and your
calculator will tell you this well
rather you'll put this into your
calculator and your calculator will tell
you this this is you're used to me right
well not quite not one is earned I can
see what the relationship is unlike - if
I think about the unit circle
where do all of my measurements on the
circle start wait a minute you they
start on the positive side the x-axis
right and if you're going - you're not
going anti-clockwise like you usually do
you're going clockwise that lunch
who's your clockwise that much into the
fourth quadrant surprise surprise you
get 300 degrees right does that make
sense so that's the meaning of the ASL
and to the reason why it gives you that
rather than that
that'll have to expand to support so let
me stop there and I think the big
takeaway from these two questions okay
number one when you have two kinds of
modifications they interact to just be
watching - 90 doesn't necessarily means
take it and go a 90 degrees like have a
look at the coefficients see what's
going on secondly when you do some
higher qualification depending on the
yes sometimes you have to provide extra
information that you usually don't the
regular side rest doesn't require
anything like that why not why doesn't
this guy require that because you don't
need to even if you want to know that
180 and 360 so some extent you've
memorized I'm like that's just audio
brainer you have to work to get there
whereas the big question if the
substantial matters work